germany and the world are finally
getting a look at the new government
that will succeed angela merkel's when
she hands over the baton next week with
a pandemic accelerating the need for a
smooth transition the social democrats
greens and liberal-free democrats are
beginning to reveal both priorities and
differences
the first three-party coalition in over
60 years says it wants to take a chance
on progress but can the world's fourth
largest economy really put values at the
center of foreign policy when it depends
on trade with china
and how to deal with russia which is
upping the pressure on ukraine and
supporting belarus destabilizing the eu
clean energy digitalization immigration
change is needed on many fronts
is germany's new government the dawn of
a modern age
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to to the point it's a pleasure
to welcome our guests thomas sparrow is
a dw political correspondent and he says
the new german government's goals are
ambitious but they will probably be
overshadowed by major international
crises
and it's a pleasure to welcome derek
scully from the new york times he says
germany's new government wants to take a
tougher line toward moscow and beijing
despite growing dependence on russian
gas and chinese car customers
feel gluck
and it's great to have with us anna
lehmann from the daily newspaper the
tuts she thinks the new coalition
promises to modernize german society
less tradition and rules more liberties
the new government doesn't officially
enter office until next week but it's
already getting a baptism by fire as it
were due to the upsurge of covet cases
in germany members of the new and old
government met this week with the heads
of state premiers to try to talk about
crisis management i'd like to talk first
of all about what we can glean from the
way they handled that and let me ask you
derek if i may and by the way i got it
wrong on your introduction you are of
course with the irish times um there's
been a lot of debate about olaf
schultz's leadership style
what could you say uh now based on what
we saw this week it had been thought he
would lead from behind but did he no he
seems to be trying to get ahead of the
curve um he's still struggling uh
throughout the covet crisis germany has
been sort of overtaken by events the
decisions are sort of all immediately
overtaken by events he seems to be
trying to get ahead of things but he's
still sort of trapped in the miracle way
of doing things but he's promised new
expedited decision making clear
competence divisions between berlin and
the federal state so i'm optimistic that
it could change but yeah germany has a
really wants to do everything thoroughly
but in a pandemic sometimes you just
have to try something quick uh rather
than wait around for consensus so i
think he's going to be a little bit more
dynamic than merkel has been you saw him
then as a as being decisive in this case
well he said i mean he's he's made very
clear decisions about what he wants this
week and but whether that will continue
in the january and february when things
start to get very messy um i'm hopeful a
fresh start you have to give somebody
the benefit of the doubt and he's been
given slight little digs towards merkel
that she's always been sort of
slower to act than really the pandemic
demands
thomas your opening statement uh said
that you thought
multiple crises could trip the new
government up certainly they are now
already engaged in crisis management
what would you say we can we can
conclude from what we've seen so far
they will have to deal first and
foremost with the coronavirus pandemic
with the fourth wave which is certainly
extremely difficult now
and i think i disagree with you when you
say that you're optimistic about olaf
schultz having a different style of
government i think we will see more of
the same style of government he was
chosen as a sort of continuation of what
we already know germany is not a country
that moves very quickly it very much
focuses on on stability and moving
slowly but surely he in fact said in an
interview this week that you know me
which is something that angela merkel
also said on various occasions so i
think we will see
more of the same style of leadership
obviously some specific new
points maybe but nothing very radical
where you can say oh this is definitely
the dawn of a new era as you as you said
germany's new government will be first
and foremost concentrated on dealing
with these crises that i mentioned not
only coronavirus but also migration
for example and it will only after that
be clear
to what extent they will be able to deal
with other issues and present their
coalition agreement 177 pages of a
coalition agreement
anna your opening statement talked about
more liberty and fewer rules and
certainly that is what the free
democrats want and what they campaigned
on now they are putting a good face on
the outcome of this week's pandemic
crisis management meeting uh but
wouldn't you say in effect they were
largely overridden by the chancellor in
waiting um
yes i think so i i can i think we can
see this week how quick things can
change especially the liberal democrats
were thinking corona and
freedom
that can go along
but now we see that the new government
will impose even tougher
rules
on fighting these
crisis
and
we are talking even about duty for
vaccination in germany
which we excluded to this point
thank you very much
some would say that the worker-friendly
social democrats
and the climate-driven dreams greens as
well as the market-oriented free
democrats are rather unlikely bedfellows
but the soon-to-be chancellor olaf
schultz says that the 3c as one when it
comes to the need for transformation
we are not interested in the lowest
common denominator but the policy of big
impacts
we want to trust ourselves and dare to
make progress
in climate protection in restructuring
our industry in modernizing the country
in strengthening social
cohesion wagon
derek scully
taking a chance on progress
that is the banner in under which this
coalition has presented its coalition
agreement is the need for progress
really that great uh are we in essence
concluding that the arrow of markle was
an era of stagnation
i don't think the era of miracle was
stagnation but was definitely
consolidation and stability i mean she
never really pushed through a
controversial reform program although
there's an awful lot that needs to be
reformed and as she's stepping down
suddenly the tide is going back and
people are seeing you know germany's
infrastructure is crumbling in many
parts of the country you know digital
infrastructure is not existing people
are using fax machines in the pandemic
and so on so um yeah there's an awful
lot to do so she wasn't really a
progressive chancellor but you could say
she had enough crisis to deal with but
it would have been interesting the
counterfactual if there hadn't been
those crisis would she have been
courageous would she have moved germany
forward i don't think so so yeah more
progress a progressive government i
think that's
really quite a positive approach and
what they're tipping on they're trying
to recall people's memories of the 1970s
willie brand as a progressive new leader
after the decades of conservative
leadership and that was a government
with the free democrats and they said
there's a social liberal consensus here
now they're trying to bring in the
greens with whom the social democrats
have also worked in the past and say
there is a common lead there is a common
denominator a central point and that is
moving the country forward progress and
there's a lot of small details in there
particularly on social policy um that
will make i think a big difference in
germany but yeah as thomas said the big
ticket items are tackling the pandemic
and energy because germany's switching
off it's less last nuclear plant next
year and where are we going to get the
the energy for for all of our devices i
want to
dive a bit deeper on that uh in a moment
but let me ask you this uh and olaf
schultz is not exactly a new face in
german politics he was in fact the
finance minister under the outgoing
government can we really expect him to
deliver renewal and change yeah in fact
olaf charles is a well-known politician
he's what you would call an apparatchik
a functionaire
but
the coalition he the coalition he leads
and the combination of parties is new
and from that you can expect a certain
kind of progress and you have indeed
some fields in the
society that will be modernized if you
think about
abolition rights about
doctors uh wanting to inform about
abolition this won't be illegal about
abortion yeah of course about abortion
and uh the right for uh people being gay
to have a legal child they will have
automatically cassidy now for a child
that's born in the in in their family
and
so on and you will have a new
immigration right which will be more
modern more open to people coming to
germany and
wanting to work there wanting to make
science and so on so in some fields of
society they really i think they really
want to modernize society and get on
move ahead
thomas in fact the coalition partners
said that they went into their
negotiations not looking at where their
red lines were where their divisions
were but at what projects they could
actually agree on initiating together we
just heard unnamed some of them there
are others like cannabis legalization uh
but beyond those sort of social issues
where do you see the biggest potential
for actual progress
one of the main challenges i think will
be implementing those changes not the
one not only the ones that you have
mentioned but also in terms of foreign
policy uh the fact that the green
politician and elena will be
the next uh foreign minister will
certainly be very interesting but my
question my main doubt is to what extent
you will be able to bring all those
points forward when you consider that
you not only have internal aspects to
discuss so the fact that you have a
three-party coalition but also when
you're dealing with other countries for
example in the european union but i want
to stress one thing one of the main
criticisms leveled against angela
merkel's government was that she wasn't
in a capacity to really present a vision
for germany that she was constantly
dealing with one crisis after the next
so the financial crisis the eurozone
crisis the migration crisis the pandemic
and that she was because she was dealing
with that she was not in a capacity to
really say my vision for germany is this
so do you see a vision in this new
government i do see a vision when this
new government if you read those 177
pages of the coalition agreement you
clearly see the goals where they want to
take the next government that's one
thing another very different thing is
whether they will actually achieve to
implement those things when you consider
that they have to deal
right from the start with a very
difficult crisis half a sentence what is
the vision well the vision is changing
on modernization modernity
bringing germany towards a modern path
and
you can fill it with content if you want
you saw that in that banner we've been
discussing it as well here it is a
vision i'm not sure whether they will be
able to implement that vision just as
i'm glamorous who wasn't and we're going
to come to exactly at that point whether
the traffic light coalition as it's
called because of the colors of the
three parties uh that join together in
it whether it sets things in motion or
slams on the brakes depends very much on
the potential for cooperation between
two men who are united by strong
ambition but diverge widely on politics
robert harbour green party co-chairman
and phd in philosophy will head the new
super ministry for climate energy and
the economy the department is tasked
with pushing forward germany's
modernization
energy transition digitization
restructuring of society and harbic
wants to make history
and at the core of this new story that
we can write together is reconciling
prosperity and climate action
for ein bergheit from volstand and
climate shots
phasing out coal expanding renewables
pricing of climate damaging exhaust
gases come at a cost
yet the turning point is expected to be
acceptable especially for business
its guarantor in germany is
traditionally the fdp its leader
christian lidner is a political
scientist and will be germany's next
finance minister he'll be a powerful
player counterpart in the new government
germany remains an advocate of sound
finances especially given many people's
concerns about inflation this is
important
in the end the finance minister decides
what funds are made available for what
and in parliament each of the governing
parties can block proposals
how much progress will the new federal
government be able to push through
and let me put that question right to
derek and the fact is that the progress
they're promising and very much of it is
about climate is going to have a very
big price tag and quite a bit of the
funding especially in the area of the
climate transformation when
transformation of energy systems will
have to come from the public hand do you
actually see this government being able
to deliver that with a finance minister
who is very attached to the so-called
debt break which is now written into the
german constitution yes i'm looking at
the traffic light behind you and right
at the top is red and the svd quite
clearly delivered on what they want
social policy so minimum wage of 12
euros stable pensions more child support
and so on and um and tackling the
housing crisis and the fdp pro-business
their supporters are lawyers doctors
they got no tax increases and that was
like the red line for them the greens
got a lot of aspiration we will we
aspire to do stuff so everyone agrees
that climate change has to happen but
when you look at what the greens got it
looks a little less
secure and i think in germany the
climate debate has yet to move beyond
the idea that the climate change can
happen it won't cost anyone it won't
harm and it won't hurt anyone it's like
a
a good value package holiday and i think
the political debate has to move on it
will actually cost and it will cost
money what are we prepared to do and
habek is trying to turn it from a
negative into progressive why don't we
use german's engineering ingenuity to
come up with a way to
paint green industrial economies and
germany can create technology and sell
it worldwide so once you bring companies
on board i think you can convince people
that it maybe will help pay for itself
at least otherwise it just looks like
big state trying to impose something on
people and that won't work with the ftp
anna the fact is that uh
leading economists say that the
coalition's program
is not financed they do not see the
sources of funding within the program as
it stands and as i said the debt break
is written into germany's constitution
are there any ways to get around it to
deliver the kind of public investment
that would be needed for example to
extend electricity transmission systems
to bring wind energy from the north to
the south to name just one example
um
yeah the
the the the tides are strong but there
are some ways small ways for instance
angela merkel's government
they
took credit over 100 uh billion euro and
i think they don't didn't need the the
all the money to solve the pandemic so
there is still some money in the bank
and this money is used for the
transformation and there will be the
possibility although the
liberal democrats try to rule it out to
take more credits uh
by companies like the barn and
households there will be shuttle
households although small yeah so
there's some off-balance sheet borrowing
uh on the part of this there will there
will be and and i wanted to say yes
there will be money for the
ecological ecological transformation for
the transformation of the economy but
the question is will there be money left
for
the social
task for the so-called burger guild for
the kindergarten sharing will there be
any money left for a substantial rise of
those benefits i don't think so social
welfare programs
thomas both uh mr linda and mr hobeck
see themselves as heading super
ministries with cross-cutting missions
with a sort of
veto power over the initiatives of other
ministers
would you say conflict is inevitable
will that put the brakes on
to use that traffic light metaphor again
i do think that there will be conflict
in this coalition it's important to
understand that german governments are
usually formed by different parties
we've had in the past the so-called
grand coalition so two parties and
conflict was already very much present
there now you have for the very first
time in many decades a three-way
coalition and these three parties are
under no circumstance natural allies
there are very different priorities that
they want to to push forward very
different priorities that are
for them red lines as you mentioned
derek and i do think that one of the
main challenges in the next four years
will be trying to bridge those
differences there's one step in that
direction namely the coalition agreement
you mentioned it as well melinda where
you said they want to focus on what's
common and not what's different but in
practical terms there will be different
priorities and it will be interesting to
see in the next four years to what
extent these parties and in particular
those two politicians are capable of
bridging their own differences let's
talk a bit about the priorities on
foreign policy because there too there
are some
some incipient divisions and the
challenges are many and tough when it
comes to foreign policy the designated
foreign minister is a newcomer
she says her lack of experience is an
asset that will help her take a fresh
approach
annelina bairbach is germany's first
female foreign minister she wants her
policies to focus on democracy and human
rights this is what the greens have
written into the coalition agreement and
is especially true regarding the
superpowers russia and china
russia's aggression towards ukraine and
china's threats against its neighbours
and aggressive trade policy could be
sanctioned more strongly in the future
eu members such as poland and hungary
are also coming under fire as their
disregard for democracy and the rule of
law are a thorn in the side of germany's
new government
can a values-based foreign policy be
successful
derek you implied with your opening
statement that it will be pretty tough
to implement a values-based foreign
policy given this country's dependent
dependence both on russia and china for
energy uh and for commercial relations
yeah i mean that's part of the medical
legacy you know in our rush to get
germany out of nuclear energy after
fukushima she wanted to have green
energy but to fill the gap they have to
import gas and
completely uh wrongs are blindsiding her
neighbors in poland and and other
eastern countries decided oh germany
will just do its own foreign policy and
our energy policy um and on on china i
mean every second volkswagen is sold now
in china um do you really think germany
will do anything to endanger volkswagen
which is partly owned by the state of
lower saxony so germany's always had a
mind view sort of the police foreign
policy it wants to have the moral
foreign policy it tells people about and
it will lecture people around the world
about what it's what they're all doing
wrong but when you actually look at how
hard knows german foreign policy is how
soft it is on certain issues it'll be
very interesting to turn up the pressure
on china and russia who are in one case
one of their best customers and the
other case the country that's helping
keeping german voters warm so um
it'll be an interesting one but she's a
trampoline let me see if
if anna agrees with you because annelina
berbach the incoming foreign minister
spoke to your paper this week and said
that she advocates and will implement a
mix of dialogue and toughness what do
you think can she bring it off
well i think she
she definitely hasn't announced a tough
approach towards uh china and russia
uh in the coalition
treaty there are trigger words like uh
hong kong like taiwan like uh rivalry of
systems and so on
and
she even didn't rule out a boycott of
the olympic games which i didn't think
don't
she never will
it will never come but anyway there is a
tougher approach towards china and i i
think she used the words uh silence is
not the diplomacy that is a criticism on
heightened mars her predecessor but it
also she also said we will uh we will
use the economic level maybe a bit uh
more
like uh china as an interest interest to
uh to enter their eur a single european
market and maybe uh we should use this
interest
to set our values so economic lovers
thomas your opening statement mentioned
uh mentioned potential crises on the
horizon certainly a number of them
emanate from russia it is stirring up
trouble at the moment with or via
belarus as well as in on the border to
ukraine
the greens and the sbd don't exactly
seem to see eye-to-eye on on russia do
they the relation to russia will be in
my opinion one of the most interesting
ones of this next government and it will
be really important to see how well or
how difficult the relationship is
between olaf schultz and vladimir putin
because you always had during the 16
years of anger merkel
one line from the german government and
that is we want to keep channels of
communication open and angela merkel and
vladimir putin even though they did not
see eye to eye on many things at least
they were in a capacity to talk to each
other and they knew each other very well
i am not sure whether that will be the
case with this new uh government and
olaf scholes it will be very important
in my view to understand how that
relationship develops and what that
means for all those practical problems
that you are mentioning it's not only
about belarus it's not only about
migration it's also about north stream
for example a very very difficult topic
for for germany the gas pipeline the gas
pipeline which will
join will bring gas from russia to to
germany i think it will be one of the
key foreign policy challenges of this
next government to really understand how
to deal with russia and how to combine
political interests so that toughness
that elena berbock has vouched for that
she wants to bring and on the other hand
very concrete very real
interests that bind these countries
together and i see it as a very
difficult challenge actually for the
next government
i'm sorry but our time is slow limited
and i don't want to miss the eu so i'm
just going to take it to come to that
point okay please
i just wanted to add uh that it will be
crucial if they if they are able to
bring the european partners on one uh
at one table if they
how how uh
how able germany will be to former or to
be a leader go ahead for coming european
uh foreign policy because uh
europe isn't is not in a good condition
right now and germany can go ahead as uh
the
the the most uh
the biggest economy we need to have
current foreign policy and they'll say
oh yeah like we should have had common
energy policy you know so germany
doesn't really have much moral
credibility to be a leadership on uni
when it's pursuing unilateral policy on
energy
let me ask you about another aspect of
eu policy if i may the coalition
agreement gives a strong nod to france
and it also talks about further
development of a quote-unquote federal
european state could we see real
movement from germany when it comes to
europe no i think um it'll be more of
the miracle line there'll be a little
bit of flexibility on the eu euro rules
but everyone i've spoken to said no
expect more of the merkel
legacy to continue with olaf schultz um
and um that will be small changes but no
revolution more evolution thomas what
area if any would you say this coalition
could bring the dawn of a modern era one
sentence
climate i hope it will be important as
derek said to change the political
discourse the political debate on
climate and the fact that the greens are
there is a particularly important issue
big question how they will implement it
thank you very much thanks to all of you
for this
this dash through all of the challenges
facing the new german government and
thanks to you for tuning in see you soon